you
this is me I'm 169 centimeters tall Iowa
61 kgs and I have horrible eyesight
this is haftorah bjornsen who plays the
mountain on Game of Thrones
Hoff's Thor is 210 centimeters tall
weighs 180 kgs and could probably eat me
for breakfast if you take any two given
people it would appear the genetic
variety in humans is incredibly vast but
surprisingly it doesn't differ as much
as you'd think human DNA is made up of
around 3 billion bits of code it's a
vast amount of data one TED talk
presenter made that figure more
impressive by wheeling out 3 bookshelves
filled with a hundred seventy five
volumes of tiny print books consisting
of 275 thousand pages these volumes
contain the first fully sequenced human
genetic code perhaps the more
interesting fact is that what separates
you from me or me from haftorah Bernsen
is the data contained on just 500 of
those 275 thousand pages much of the
rest is currently a mystery human DNA
sequencing has come a long way in a very
short time 17 years ago the project that
produced the first sequence code cost
about a hundred million dollars today
you can have your DNA sequenced for
under a thousand bucks in 2012 the
scientific community had another major
breakthrough a technology called CRISPR
allowed scientists to accurately and
affordably cut and paste bits of
information within DNA a procedure that
used to be reserved for huge budget
projects can now be quickly replicated
by students in a good bio lab the
ability to selectively apply genetic
traits in humans is fast approaching
soon parents will be able to edit eye
color or physical fortitude among
countless other traits as well as
completely screen out disease or
imperfections as the world approaches
this massive change it would be wise to
consider some of the possible
consequences as with any new technology
there are inherent risks when editing
human DNA geneticist will have to have
the utmost care for the underlying
system much of those 275 thousand pages
of data are simply filled with long
stretches of the letter n those passages
represent bits of code that the
technology of the day couldn't decipher
at first it will be like a computer
science student playing around with
existing code whatever changes he makes
may have unintended consequences and
will probably not be for the best as the
technology becomes more mainstream it
will become more available to the
average individual what happens when
young parents can't
forward to edit negative traits after
the child they're expecting less
scrupulous gray market geneticists could
offer reduced rates with lower standards
possibly introducing unforeseen genetic
problems into their customers many
experts believe that the best way to
combat that kind of situation is to
prevent individual labs and governments
from controlling the growth of the
market like the way GMOs have developed
if this new technology is nurtured in a
public collaborative environment led by
genetic experts the outcome could be
much more positive genetic tinkering
needs to be developed in a controlled
humanitarian manner to avoid the face
that's befallen GMOs which are now often
referred to as frankenfoods and have a
negative connotation when they could
realistically help end world hunger one
facet of humanity that must be respected
is diversity diversity has gotten the
human race through some very challenging
times and is absolutely essential to any
evolving system take for example your
average City most successful cities are
home to a variety of different
businesses you've got your grocery
stores your coffee shops and your retail
outlets among others some of those
businesses will fail and some will
flourish as they always do the more
diversity you have in your city the
better off you'll be
it's the difference between having a bad
year and losing one barbershop among ten
diverse stores or nine barbershops among
ten similar stores the same is true
among humans if generations in the
future become more homogeneous will be
more susceptible to disease and genetic
conditions that could cause massive
societal damage genetic engineering also
raises questions of parenting and of the
essence of life itself when this
technology becomes mainstream will it be
a parent's obligation to have her child
modified most people would agree that
screening out the predisposition for
alcoholism or Alzheimer's would be a
good choice but where should we stop
eliminate blindness sure what about a
standard height for males or a standard
weight for females what skin color is
the most desirable do we want a race of
super athletes musicians professional
bowlers the temptation of making a
designer baby will be very real and
maybe that's okay but you have to think
at what point does the child stop being
itself and become a product of
prepackaged super genes then again is
that all we are in the first place mine
stuck and more or less randomly
generated strings of data are we
individuals or are we just the
inevitable end result of our genetic
code perhaps in the coming years
scientists will be able to shed more
light on those lines of ends and unravel
the mystery hidden in our DNA maybe the
next generation of children will be
beautiful brilliant 6-foot tall blond
hair blue eye
Professional Bowlers as this technology
develops and we are still a good way off
from seeing modified embryos brought to
term it's important to keep in mind that
there's no such thing as a perfect human
being genetic traits necessitate
trade-offs you wouldn't see a
six-foot-tall jockey or a four and a
half foot tall strongman perceived
imperfections are what make us unique
and define us as a species so look
forward to destroying blindness muscular
disorders Alzheimer's and countless
other blights and remember that your DNA
is just as special as hostile bjornsen
and almost as special as mine as always
my videos are intended to spark your
curiosity on the subjects I present if
you're interested in learning more about
genetic engineering check out the links
in the description if you enjoyed this
video please take a moment to subscribe
to my channel by clicking here your
support really does make all the
difference
leave a like or a comment down below and
share your thoughts on what the future
of humanity will look like you can check
out my last video by clicking here or
watch them all by clicking here thanks
for watching and I'll see you next week